[Music]
all right ken so on your show you talk
about work and career and purpose and
with that comes uh all the trending news
of remote work
and now the shift from remote work to
hey guys we're coming back to the office
oh boy and it's created a big stir
hasn't it oh man i mean you have people
that are up in arms about this you know
there's data out there that says that uh
nearly 60 of people said that they'll
quit their job
if they have to return to the office wow
people that are remote workers i mean
they have really jumped into the whole
sweat suits and rocky road ice cream you
know it's amazing because just a few
years ago remote work was a rare concept
there wasn't a ton of full-time career
remote jobs out there yeah you know more
and more people were doing it but we're
talking about a small percentage of the
american workforce then the pandemic
hits and of course everybody goes home
for a while right and uh so you get some
people that go man this is my jam and
boy by the way fine
until you you potentially hurt your
professional possibilities and your
income yes so i want to show everyone an
example of the kind of stuff we're
talking about the stances people are
taking and of course we're going back to
tick tock uh ken's favorite social media
platform i love to be on the talk and so
this one's about why are remote workers
being forced back in the office check
out this video
i still find it very hard to believe
that a lot of corporations are forcing
their employees to come into the office
after working from home for two years
it's very obvious that you do not need
to sit and look at them all day long now
i'm not naive i know that many of these
corporations have these big buildings
and major real estate investments they
just simply just can't go under so
they need to get the employees back in
the building and they need them to use
the building otherwise they'll have to
renegotiate these leases get out of
these contracts that they're in and they
probably just don't want to do that and
it may not be
um financially beneficial for them to do
so so i get that
but it's just always a situation of
choosing business over employee
well-being because if employees want to
stay home and they did a great job
working remotely when they were forced
to and now they want to stay at home
full-time why are you forcing these
hybrid models or them to just come back
to office
oh there it is all right so
this is a common sentiment this is not
this is not an aberration it's not
something out of left field this is this
lady is expressing what millions of
americans believe um i i take issue with
the fact that corporations are asking
people to come back in a hybrid model
i'll break that down in a second but
corporations aren't asking people to
come back because they need to use the
building
you know that's that is not the issue
okay
they if if they don't want to use the
building and they wanted to to go all
remote they could get out of those
leases they could sell those buildings
yeah and that's an example of this right
down the road here from ramsey is a
healthcare company yeah that has been
empty empty completely empty so it's not
about usage it's not like a country club
and we've got a bunch of workout
machines that are going to get rusty if
people aren't on that is not what
corporations are doing what they want is
they want more teamwork collaboration
and a better culture
i mean i'm reading these headlines every
day
and and you see the ceos that are saying
we want a return to work to a hybrid
model and it's for reasons of we believe
we need that connectivity
and we as human beings are relational
now here's the thing for all these folks
that like this this lady uh who are so
against it um there are there are
millions of people who are going i'm
lonely i'm disconnected it's created
depression a lack of productivity
because you're just always in the same
environment there's no there's no
boundaries between your home life and
your work life
so there's a lot of negatives to this
work from home uh this idea of
flexibility and then i want to just
comment on hybrid so hybrid is i mean
it's it's letting people work from home
a couple days a week or three days a
week in the office two or three days a
week and this is becoming widely adopted
to the point that i think a couple of
years from now i think it will probably
be
the uh most common form of work
environment that we see as a hybrid
model i just think that's where we're
headed but my goodness
you're willing to not go back to work
you're willing to change jobs to quit to
start over to maybe put yourself in a
position where you gotta scramble all
because you don't want to leave the
house
i think you have to be cautious with
that
you know but you do what you do you
uh but i would not make this a line in
the sand yeah not when they're offering
you the hybrid model and to be clear we
are not against people working remotely
now at ramsey we all work in the
building and that's something you know
when you sign up for this place this is
how we operate right but the idea of we
were in person then we weren't remote
and now we refuse to go back and they're
forcing us
i just don't believe in this narrative
well this is the wrong this is a very
good point george the word forcing are
they forcing you there's no armed guard
showing up at your house telling you you
have to go in they're saying if you want
to work here
we need you in the office you have free
will
this is america
you can say pound sand i'm out
you know if that's what you want to do
do that don't gripe and act like the
evil corporate man wants me back in the
office because he needs to see his cubes
filled this is nonsensical snowflakery i
just made that that's a great word i
like that yeah so what it comes down to
ken is you're not entitled to anything
because you're an employee
you are entitled to your opinion and you
are entitled to your choices oh
that's what you're entitled to here's
the takeaway outside of that you're not
if you want to work remote go find a job
that allows you to work remote fantastic
is that it that's the summary we solved
it
yeah wow
they should put us in charge of
something but here's the deal this is
good there listen this has always been a
money show it's always going to be money
focused
what i'm cautioning is is that you were
to take a step backwards professionally
and financially all because
you feel you have the right to work in
your conditions
all the time and the company has no
opinion about it it's nonsense
so don't hurt yourself over this get
over it yeah i i gotta tell you i don't
see what the big deal is
going back to the office uh the hybrid
model i i can see if you love remote
work and you can get full-time remote
work go for it i'm all for it be remote
be i i can't be away from people that
long i got deep problems you love me too
much i love george i need to be around
george you know what i'm saying said no
one ever but what's the problem with a
little bit of work in the office for
some collaboration some culture it's
like we're ignoring the fact that we're
humans and that we're relational yeah
well one thing's for sure work has got a
lot more complicated and you've got to
start figuring out where are my values
what do i want for myself and for my
family where do we want to live and the
beautiful thing is you get to decide
you have free will you have industry
over your life you control your destiny
and the moment you think it's in the
hands of the employer the evil greedy
crooks i got to just back up and say hey
hey you have choices remember that take
control